This
is the Cal N.E.H. American English dialect recordings collection produced
with funding from the National Endowment for the Humanities and the Center for Applied Linguistics.
This is tape number thirty six side a.
Your
family doing all sorts of work.
Well you see we live so Mary grandma and yes Larry.
That is your own Christmas or Christmas tree. Well over a year
doesn't matter which way are having people over
there because most people come there
on that evening or Christmas early and our
folks and there's a Christmas. A morning sent out here
right here with us here vice chairman there you know and they're being
our Hashanah airline. And they're so. Sometimes right to
Christmas this year by the way to Christmas. Here with
the way to my grandma's hairdo and I have a whole bunch of
you know cars here you can sell us right now
are there there were a lot of
pheromones and verify that twelve
here that two of that service to him live.
Well will be there.
My dear. My my my aunt
Dora my uncle was sure Michael. Archer.
And Mary. There are some of us and I have been there I'll
be
there as well. Sometimes no one can make it you know
but you know most of the day myself I said.
And then go out there. Everyone of running says you know like.
My answer revue to my surprise you know. And I am very suspicious of him as
a contact high or Kyle says Jim like two or three of the almost
bring it there you know
and I want to find their sense and. And then as a morning. A grandmother use
that in light of the sanction. Is I
really enjoy where they are where they all go for it I do
not know what he did. In that Grandma.
My Aunt Maggie nice to the that she lived
in Tulsa Oklahoma and then I work I live now.
And Mary lives in Tulsa Bailey lives
in Missouri.
And I do or not I all
is but from Tim I am dualism finally to my atheist
lives in progress and our society. But not the
center. Here. All the brothers
live and active about that.
And also just as
for him I have your vet. Yabby and.
We're going to have the backing of the group.
Yes I do like Christmas present drowning here with that
very well as you
say one time there is the director key is
nice and all the girl is the
turnout. That's. Now and I just you know Lester. Back
to their own family. I
don't hear. And you know they don't bring their.
So they want to live no one here they
don't turn on niceness that. And we haven't
heard about Moore's law. You know what you're going to
give your mother.
Well I haven't decided yet. Because you
know I look at Caroline's you know the whole bunch of different things you know from all
of this shit out selective. So I don't
know. Do you have any
children. Well you say have you found on
the ground. To wait and.
Then like if I help Mom
I'm still paying me no extras.
And if I act over that as there's a dish
is for to wait that didn't last.
And then she would give you that twenty thirty dollars because they
are one of these parasites there are three major
Nadler and they cost that much money and she you know for me
now let's really leave this guy. You know but because of that damage
that you have we do extra chores. In your
own. Well maintained
the same way we do have to calling.
As one sometimes you know that he implies a sense of pride.
She has five others.
Anyway. But you know.
Well you see I
was going by this tear OK having trusted twenty
dollars and care attention on stuff. That's been in cars that
already all together.
You know and I was kind of either in.
I don't know off on course or not paying. You know one of momma type of
the order for the care loan. The fact that that much money there will be.
The
order. And McGovern. But when she takes it
or the city and Iraq if she ever wants
to Vasant them and then sure rather than you know where she wants
to say the
further you know the order of us in the
room and they are found to have met.
If you are from the cause.
Well. She bought them again rewards and
fears for our children. And there's some sense it in Spencer. CAROLINA.
You know what they are not all that she says so many leave who want
national no or break bless no less is who
bails you out or step.
Or do you say.
Well we've got two dogs that actually they're not mine.
That are as my dad. But. Well.
There are really here that's not the one I'm
setting them up. That I don't know they're very good to
her not we have
her. We just got like.
The Governator. If we
do this. We have to say we've got this current life that I have
NOT REAL be ready for a good size and then like after is one across
three that was that day that we plan luck Kornel
there and you know to tell you is a seventh day that everyone has
a card playing and last names other than this others are no plans.
Back since my this as.
As you know that some thousand plan. You know these are
things we miss stories about hard to
deal with yes I do have candy and
other Tell me about the party.
I can. Well I
don't camp are massive you know I mean I can not
mama have to wash the drawers and. I'm almost nice calling hours from my
and his legs that
then I will use to my G.'s. I have to
squeeze
N.G.'s as no other guys really stand in. Says I.
Well it's got these
little halo. I think
and they're brown and there was this one artist named condemn and this may be
bigger than your own words
there and that that is not all
that bad. Yeah that was all he
has used to every question then is it pops you
know. That's what I want to have I have this. I have this
thing again I was doing
that and she'll try and show you like this
like her is good. Oh yes I
love that I'm interested in this went last weekend
the
last book A Woman have found you know
the previous owners because or six their family and
everyone in our family. Except my mom crazy that my
sister that they are you know. And so we can the core of
the idea that meant.
Well we could have corn you know these real three years. It
really well pretty gritty you know where the
M. prisoners froze you know the common right to. The
woman of her years and in return.
Just as a day that we the whole bunch of players.
Yes there's yes in that moment and they are
either. Because you know she has scaled back a heart attack
that they're not your own
or can now talk maybe
if you do not understand. Them. The.
You don't get
what you say you may be more or
less had to go to the doctor to look.
Well or detect.
Oh yeah I've done that. But. This one
here this as the know you are just was for Mr
Williams OK I'll have this one here when I was in the second
grade Mr Wayne came in Lucky you know I just learned
by and he says who all say you know and that is you can go
home and I don't even feel bad I know it all and
so I
says. If you're so bad you know because then
that was suddenly all just a second grade as I was there you know he's the kind of like
you home who says I got hold of that them tight in
there and I have that resulted in the most
serious about the I have chicken pox. Oh god you
have proved that case every
now and it was gross that on my i scratch and
we don't
talk. And just it's so
bad and I'm right in the middle of last night it was
my fault I had and I was little even had that's not
all that I remembered it. Mom said.
You have a big space race. I mean.
I have. If you can stay home. My
dad or sister or my
grandma better. She or if it's VERY better sense
than to go into the drug store and get a prescription.
But alas you will never use mass Pern
Canyon just whatever and. She don't give you that name.
She'll take your temperature you
know sort of it's all in there and. Can't.
But now she's given us this
violence Amundsen of. So we want to tell.
That issue and I already had more than that you know
right. But. Well let's.
Well sometimes I'm sure though we've got quite a bit. There you know and mom have to
get
up around six thirty and she has to get really you know go to
work and we have you know you have until that fifteen or
seven and then she faces our
breakfast every morning and then she goes on the work but then used to go.
When she didn't she just that
for lack of them were sent in on Saturdays she had to
work and then.
We would. And should fix is where with school she picks these
powers and duties who can apply you know and we just talk them through
about ones not to press around you know and they were so good and you
know she's YES ME A GOOD. You know kind of a cry. You know
have her own for you know that she
can and has been.
Every kilometer the sand where she goes to and she gets the
flags Payson Coke's you know instead right now we're sort of shorter men.
Because Christmas coming up you know I know
that we're going to say she's going to give all of us a call for
Christmas and you know this guy instead of us that is
yet for well actually a travesty our guys
to us as a first person that he's only going to get a few
Thanks to Chris. Because you know a basket cost about
fifty dollars. Do you know
a good one and it's going to
cost quite a bit that I have mine just
to have and scary to know about the caution as I have that now
the school sanctioned their own doesn't look like it's going to get tore through
or do you have just
the other little about a lot of
things that sometimes always
know. Though that it was established and others
are still. Are they are they
as it was in there and I was going to sleep on
that then
then or I didn't want to listen then on the phone and
I'm Joel can I have a ventilator she wanted to
call that you know and don't let it in there first you know and seven other back
up. And then I have a
finger left there and he smash mouth anchor. I guess it was actually there when
he didn't say anything either that way sort of in a fight you know and
that and then mom says well can I. What it was
line you know and I
want you and Canada says well I joined they both
wanted
to follow that catch you
have now and I'm I says.
Are you know. Then and.
Nothing which are now why you know I didn't really want to know you know but it was best kill my and then.
Then why then I'll join in a
room and one of their plaster
know and write a book of my goodness. But throughout the day.
She grabbed I have
for. You have your get ready.
But then if she
did say the ground and if it don't.
Well she relied on Grouse all that much but then
she was a super And you know this that real bad.
I got a long
time but she was great as rage.
Just. Did you what if she says if you work with our hands she can only
have one of those a day. Well as I get back and you get
one
within the day she M. that is
which and Main can I know it by.
And Joel. He led this jar there now open the door and roll them bro.
And Joe go listen for that because Mama told him to send going to cut it up.
And she would mena and with the sewage out of there
are you know if I thought of that it was funny I find that.
I you know I didn't let her know that it was
by her it was never
good for her. Of his
jewel to hear that he's you know pretty husky you
know he was
always. And always no risk to run a little girl is pretty strong
to get me back.
But there were
drugs. And then you know I told them and I
know and her
husband my dad came to have a Louis by.
Now it was always.
It was some time anyway and I tend to think was a sign
that they were supposed to go to work for the drone or he
says. I'm militia in the West and that inside I know I had
a film of the shooting
go in there says. Ruby
if God calls you know. Your
boss just tell him that I've gone to the hospital and her next day or so you
know he's joking around you know telling
that sort of you believe
it has a doctor you know. And then they call that
about five or six calls in the morning. No less it
was on a Saturday
I natter Sunday morning one I call
that Mama may I mean they were just nourishing us and mom whenever
she gets numbers. She asked and do said she could I have
just left that she just never over.
But then what happened during the was that I had gone in this
car and there'd been a source that they couldn't say you know because of the source
code but. From the how
around to the dirt road ran a score and a crack. I
guess I had to go up and I
just turned you know and there was director on a journey.
That they were on drugs that I don't know I have no there but his leg
was broke and they said it was
real just just hanging.
And his neck was
broke. In Monday.
Gregory Bryan. I mean if it was
are criticizing Brian. Somewhere but.
Mama wouldn't say we had a gust
I. Mom's a Christian and
she called Care Core and care on him can then pick this
up and to. Over to their
half they've only got two more you not know and
then all of us here's one of their six Sherry she's my
daughter she was and
they were way over there and
they wouldn't tell Mom wouldn't tell us that they had a blood clot.
Then they call that
my mom to stop the care
of their day in my charger you know but you
know and then I tell
them. I'm sure glad he made. This is by.
Now I don't know if we are the best I've heard of.
Well as yet idea but it took so much that I said story hours to get them
out what I regard as a trip to so torn up
and broken in.
Here he was that have been around two weeks now there is staying there
for twenty eight
days on that Sunday to the next and the next.
That's been the very next step forward for you and say OK.
Well yes they say that they either disabling the
last time
we have you no longer or going to
decide. But I thank goodness I went
to the.
Yes there for a while a long time ago here care
is clear to me. Here. Yes.
As we see it the day
and the third four months that just happened.
Here here or here
on Tuesday. And then now.
He sort of Manchuria just a little bit. Not that bad.
You like. The
the you know the
creativity quit
drinking.